what in the plate SETI other plate relax
lunch is on me why do the cats sit in
front of a computer to keep an eye on
the mouse
why do golfers win two pairs of pants in
case they get a hole-in-one why do the
mathematical tree fall over cuz it had
no real roots every restaurant is a
drive-through
if you drive hard enough so the cops
arrested two teenagers one was drinking
battery acid and the other one was
eating fireworks they charged one led
the other one off why do gorillas have
such big nostrils because they have big
fingers what is four wheels and flies a
garbage truck what the water say to the
boat nothing they just waved why did the
one-headed man cross the road to get to
the second-hand store why did the turkey
cross the road to show that it wasn't
chicken why didn't the orange cross the
road just ran out of juice and why
didn't the skeleton cross the road that
he just didn't have the guts
why was the yellow fits the textbooks so
good at sports you had a lot of
exercises why was the Cambridge textbook
always so sad he had too many problems
what lights up a soccer stadium a soccer
match which building in the school is
going to explode first power block which
building has the most stories the
library which building has the most
caffeine tea block what you call a pig
that does karate a pork chop why did the
photo go to jail because it was framed
which teacher was hit by lightning mr.
Armitage he's an excellent conductor
which teacher is bad at high jump mr.
low which teacher doesn't like the story
of Noah's Ark mr. flood which teaches
the best at conducting heat mr. steel
which teaches the best chef mrs. cook
which teaches the best at Korean dancing
mr. Tsai which teaches the best at
everything miss the best did you hear
the joke about the bird food bed not
tell you you might spread it did you
even joke about the roof never mind it
don't just go over your head put in the
blanket say to the bed don't worry I got
you covered how does Justin Bieber's
steak who
he sits next to his fans why did the
baby strawberry cry cuz his parents were
in a jab if you have nine oranges in one
hand and ten lemons in the other what do
you have really big hands if you have
nine Mars bars and ten sneakers in the
other hand what do you get diabetes
you're probably gonna get diabetes when
the police was surrounded by flies who
did they call for backup
the SWAT team what's a cat's favorite
color why cuz they're shellfish who is
the roundest knife at King Arthur's tape
prince why name milking stools I only
have three legs
cuz the cows got the other I didn't like
my haircut at first but I think it's
starting to grow on me
you should never write with a broken
pencil it's just pointless did you hear
about the fire the cadet camp it was
intense why did the complex number get
suspended from school because they had a
principal argument a neutron walks into
a bar and asks how much for beer
bartender says for you no charge and
Adam walks into the bar and says I've
lost an electron the bartender says are
you sure the Adam replies I'm positive
why couldn't the children see a movie
about pirates it was rated R why did he
everyone go to the party and mushrooms
house cuz they heard he was a fun guy
why didn't people go to the party
carrots apartment cuz they heard there
wasn't much room much much much room
mushroom did you hear about the antennas
that got married the ceremony wasn't
very good but the reception was awesome
did you hear about the restaurant on the
moon the freezer okay but there's just
no atmosphere did you hear about the
carbon that turned into a diamond I
think he's been under a lot of pressure
lately
one day I crossed the road I walked into
a bar and they were changing a lightbulb
and then I realized my life is just one
big joke